This weekend we have reached a turning
point in the war. It is possible that in
a few hours or by tomorrow we will reach
the point of no return. Donald Trump has
threatened the Iranians saying that on
Tuesday, if the Iranians still refuse to
open the Strait of Humus, then the
Americans will destroy
the Iranian power plants
and bridges and universities. Basically,
the Americans will start attacking
critical civil infrastructure which will
force Iranians to strike hard against
the GCC, the oil fields, the
dissalination plants, the universities
as well. And this would mean that the
world would lose 20% of its energy
supply.
And this would be catastrophe for the
global economy.
It would uh de-industrialize the world
and would create global famine among
other problems. Okay. So next few hours,
next day um we could reach the point of
no return in this war. Hopefully Trump
is bluffing because he has known to
bluff before.
In fact, he's issued many ultimatums to
Ran before and then he sort of tackled,
right? Trump always chickens out and he
said, "You know what? I said a day, but
I'll give you a week instead." But this
time, I want to show you that it's
different. I want to show you that this
weekend the Americans went allin. They
launched a ground invasion. It failed.
And instead of saying, you know what,
um, we probably can't beat Iran. Let's
negotiate a peace deal. What the
Americans will do is they will go all in
now and launch a full-scale ground
invasion called the national draft and
the world will never be the same again.
Okay, so this is a tweet that Donald
Trump um sent to the Iranians and he
calls them crazy bastards.
Um and he says praise be to Allah. So a
lot of people think he is now the
reigns. Clearly he's angry at the
Radians. All right.
All right. So, um,
the Americans and the Israelis have
constantly escalated attacks against
civilian targets in Iran. So, uh, Trump
ordered the destruction of Iran's
largest bridge. Okay.
All right. Right here. Right. You guys
see that? Okay. And this is considered a
war crime because you're not supposed to
t target target civilian infrastructure.
Now, you can make the argument that this
is dual use, meaning that the military
uses it as well, but everything is dual
use, right? Because the military also
uses water, they also use electricity,
their kids also go to university. So, um
there's a great fear now that we already
at the point of no return. And the
Iranians themselves have promised to
start to attack universities in the GCC
as well. Okay. In retaliation.
Um so if Trump were to destroy the
Iranian power plants, uh this would be
devastating for the Iranian economy. And
there's news now that Iran is organizing
a
uh protest where young people are asked
to go to power plants and form a human
chain so that if the jets come destroy
the power plants they will be destroyed
as well. Um so some people think that
okay this is the Iranians calling the
bluff of Trump. That's not a good idea
because the first day of the war, the
Americans killed uh 168 school girls in
southern Iran. So this shows that the
Iranian the Americans and the Israelis
don't really care about human life. Um
but by doing this, if the Americans
actually do destroy uh power plants and
they do kill a lot of young people in
the process, what this would do is
galvanize the nation into total war.
Okay. So what's important to understand
is that um throughout this war there
have been
different voices in Iran. Okay. Some
like the the Asafic Refugeary Guard want
total war. But there are also some who
are worried about the economic damage
because of this war. They're also
worried about giving power to too too
much giving too much power to the
military. Okay. But if Donald Trump goes
and attacks these power plants, then the
Iranians will be going to total war,
they will be totally committed to
destroying the American military
presence in the Middle East as well as
the global economy. Okay?
And unfortunately, the Americans in the
Shis don't really care because they're
committed to destroying um Iran as a
viable nation state. Already we are
seeing increases in fuel prices. Okay?
So if you are in the
um
red, it means that you've seen prices go
up a lot. Okay, if you are in the red,
so America, Australia, um they've seen
prices skyrocket. Uh China has also seen
prices skyrocket as well as well as
Europe. This is only just the beginning.
Um we can we can expect gas prices to
skyrocket
so much that essentially collapses the
civilian aviation industry meaning
meaning that in the future you want to
fly it might cost you 10 times as much
as it does now. Okay. And this will
happen very very quickly. But again the
main issue and I need to emphasize this.
The main issue is not the fuel. The main
issue is the fertilizer.
And the fertilizer is important because
you need fertilizer to grow food. And we
are in the planting season. You guys
don't know this, but it is because
fertilizer that we are that we are
allowed to support 8 billion people. If
we do not have access to fertilizer, we
can only grow enough food to support one
to two billion people.
And unfortunately this means that Africa
um and parts of South South Asia a lot
of people there will starve to death. So
the main concern is famine. Okay, not
airline tickets.
All right, let's continue. All right, so
as this war is progressing, we need to
step back and recognize that this is a
global war. So, um, the the Ukrainians
use drones to attack and destroy an oily
pot, an oil terminal in Russia. And this
means now that 40% 40% guys of Russia's
oil exports have gone offline,
right?
So what's happening is that not only is
the server home was closed but the
Americans are also attacking uh Russia's
oil. Okay. So you have drone strikes in
terminals but also you don't rec you
don't see this in the news but also
there's um a basically a naval blockade.
So if you are a Russian uh oil tanker
the American if the Americans come and
catch you they'll take your oil. Okay.
So this basically piracy.
So in other words, the American strategy
before was okay, before we were the
world's uh global reserve currency and
as a result
we uh encouraged global trade but now
that we are not but now that our economy
is suffering well let's just control the
sea lanes. Okay. So that's American
strategy moving forward. All right. Um,
some major news from Germany is that if
you are a German male under 45, okay,
basically from 17 to 45, this age room,
this age group, you are not allowed to
leave the country for more than 3 months
without
army permission.
This is a prelude to a national draft.
Okay? And why is Germany doing this?
Because Germany is an industrial nation.
And if Russian energy supply goes
offline, if energy from the GCC goes
offline, Germany has no choice but to
remilitarize and create its own energy
supplies. Okay? So, Germany must go to
war. It has absolutely no choice in the
matter.
All right? So, let's talk briefly about
what's going to happen over the next
year. So as I said before, the United
States was the global reserve currency
and that mean meant basically that for
every transaction that you made with US
dollars, they could tax you. Okay?
Because they could inflate the price of
the US dollar. But now that people are
choosing to opt out of the US dollar,
for example, in China, people are buying
more gold, right? And people are using
other currencies. America in order to
maintain its empire has to change its
strategy. Now the main source of
American power is its ability to control
sea lanes. Okay? Because it has military
bases all around the world. Okay? So in
the red these are all areas with US
bases and before it used these US bases
in order to maintain global trade. But
with nations choosing
to opt out of your system, now your
option, now your strategy is to blockade
them, right? Could enable blockade,
starve them of resources, which forces
them to come beg to you for trade
access. Okay, so we've gone from a
strategy where America guaranteed global
trade to America basically being a mafia
state, being pirates and allowing you to
use um seal lanes and giving you trade
access. Okay, does that make sense? And
believe it or not, but America does not
actually need to do that much work in
order to control trade around the world.
it just it just needs to control certain
trade or um certain choke points. Okay.
So the Panama Canal is one choke point
and that's why about a third of
um America's navy is deployed to the
Caribbean right now. All right. And its
main purpose is to block off trade
um in the Western Hemisphere. So if you
are China, if you are Japan and you are
South Korea, if you want to access
Western resources, Western hemisphere
resources, you need the permission from
the US government. And the um example of
course is Venezuela where they remove
the president and now they basically
have a blockade over Venezuela. And so
the Venezuelan government is very
cooperative. Okay, they're basically
over obedient. There's um and so what we
can expect next is for Trump to exert
authority over Greenland. Why? Because
this is the Arctic choke point. Okay,
which gives you access to Canada uh and
to Europe as well. We're going to also
expect um America to basically create a
choke point over the straight home
moves. Right? So right now the issue is
that the Iranians control the st. But
the Americans can also choose to
blockade the shoo. Okay? Does that make
sense? All right. The major choke point
in the world of course is something
called the straight of Malaka.
Why? Because that this is where China
gets most of its resources from Africa
from the Middle East. Okay, through this
very small choke point and again
unfortunately there are lots of US
military bases in this area. So as long
as America is able to maintain these
three major choke points, the Panama
Canal um the Middle East and Malaka oh
and also sorry Greenland as well then
America can control naval access okay
trade access maritime navigation it can
control all these things and so what's
going to happen is this the big event
this year moving forward is that Russia
will militarize its shuttle fleet.
Okay. Basically, Russia has a channel
fleet about a thousand uh ships. It will
provide mercenaries to the ships and
then it will start to uh engage America
in the oceans. The point is not to
defeat the American Navy. You can't do
that. Okay? The point is to create a war
of attrition where you know that the
Americans will have problems rebuilding
these ships and these ships are pretty
old as well and the sailors are on them
are pretty tired. So you just force them
into conflict and then this naval
capacity of the United States will
degrade over time. Okay, this is
something to look out for over the next
year or two years. There's conflict in
the seas that will arise between Russia
and the United States. Okay. And then
you ask yourself, okay, well, how about
China? Because China is actually the
main beneficiary of um oceanic trade and
China is going to do China, which is to
say that China is going to try to
negotiate between Russia and America and
try to triangulate the two and try to
come to peace with all two. Okay? And
that often means paying both off, paying
both the Russians and paying the the
Americans off. And and that's what
that's what happened in May when Trump
visits China, right? Okay. We'll talk
talk more about that later on.
Okay. So, the big news this weekend and
this something I want to focus on for
the rest of lecture is
the Americans said that one of their one
of their jets, it's called an F-15. This
about a $90 million plane. Okay. It was
shot down
over uh Iran. Okay. Um basically in uh
this area right here.
And you ask yourself, okay, the
Americans have aeros supremacy over
Iran. So how is it possible for the
Iranians shoot down um a plane? And the
answer is this. The US Air Force is not
designed to fight a long war. It's
designed to fight at most a two-eek war.
If you fight for too long, you have
certain issues. One issue is
maintenance.
Okay? Which is these are very expensive
planes. They require a lot of
maintenance. But if they're flying too
much, if they're if they have too much
work, they suffer from wear and tear.
Okay. Another issue is just fatigue
where these pilots are being asked to
work too hard, they get tired, they get
lazy. Now the last thing is this Iranian
um resilience.
Okay? And all this means is that as
you're bombing the Iranians, the
Iranians have to figure out how to
strike back at you. Their radar systems
don't really work. So what they use is
use heatseeking missiles. Okay? So
rather rather than trying to figure out
where you are, this five missiles up in
the air and hope and hope to log on to
your hit signature and knock you down.
Okay? All right. So over time, all this
means is that as this war progresses, if
you insist on fighting a ear war, you're
going to lose more and more planes as
your pilots get tired, as men issues
arise, as Iranians become much more
creative in their response. Okay? So, a
pilot was shot down and two pilots were
able to eject safely out of their plane.
Now, it is the policy of the American
military to leave no man behind.
And this is the and and the Americans
are one one of the few militaries
actually do this where if you're behind
enemy lines, they will try to rescue
you. and they spent years training you
on how to invade uh enemy capttors.
They'll spend a lot of resources trying
to save you. And the propaganda is that
this is to show you how Americans really
value
uh human life and it's something
Americans are very proud of. But another
reason why Americans do this is this
optics,
which is that that the Americans
believe that the military is invincible
and they spend a lot of money and
resources in order to create this image,
this aura of invisibility and
invisibility. So if the Iranians are
able to capture a pilot and have him
appear on Iranian TV, this is a huge
propaganda win for the Iranians. Meaning
this meaning that if the Americans the
Americans will try your best the
Americans will try their best to save
you but they can't save you and there's
a risk that the enemy will capture you
they rather have you killed okay because
they can't afford to lose this
propaganda war for the Americans
everything is optics as I will show you
later on this is going to be a huge
issue in this war okay as this war
progresses now there are a lot of issues
with
um the story that's being told to us.
Okay, the Americans said that they have
successfully evacuated both pilots. They
have saved both pilots. But the issue is
this. The issue is that we know that
um the Americans created a makeshift
landing strip, basically an airport, a
small airport 200 kilometers
from
um where the airman actually
was knocked down. So he had he had to
hike a long way in order to get to
Lenning strip. Also he was injured. I
mean he he broke his ankle or something.
Okay, so that was very very hard to do.
Also, he's trying to evade uh enemy
capture. Okay, so this story doesn't
really make sense. And why did the
Americans decide to create a landing
strip here rather some place someplace
closer? And why would you need 155
planes for this operation? Right? Aren't
you better off with just one or two to
like avoid enemy fire? So, this is a
very strange story, but it gets weirder.
Okay.
Um,
it turns out that the Americans
basically spent a lot of resources to to
save the pilot. It took 48 hours and the
CIA created a lot of distractions and
the um Americans spent spent a lot of
resources to save the man while the
Iranians were trying to capture him.
Okay. And this led to the destruction of
very expensive American planes. Okay.
The these are called C130. So they're
transport planes and they were destroyed
in the rescue operation. Now the
American story is that these planes were
caught in the sand. They couldn't lift
off. So Del Force, the commandos who are
trying to save the pilot, they blew up
the um planes themselves. Okay. And as
you can see, the Americans in this
operation, they lost a lot of expensive
planes. The estimates are the Americans
lost $300 million in planes. And even
though the Americans say that there were
no casualties in this rescue, we can
expect that there were casualties in
this rescue because a lot of planes were
destroyed. Okay? And again, these are
very expensive planes.
And throughout this war, the Americans
have lost quite a few planes. Um the C
um uh 130
are extremely um expensive. Okay.
All right.
Okay. All right. So, this has led people
to
question whether or not the narrative is
true or not. Now, you can make the
argument that this narrative is true.
You can make the argument that the
American military prides itself on no
man left behind. So, they will do
whatever they can move heaven and earth
to save that person. And that's
something that the Americans take pride
in. But again there are issues with this
narrative. So this is um a man named
Arnon Petron and on Twitter he explains
that the story doesn't really make
sense. Okay. So the first thing is how
did a
fighter jet American fighter jet get
knocked down in Iran when the Americans
have said that they have a supremacy
over the country? Another issue is that
um the weapons director, sorry, the
weapons systems officer is a colonel. A
colonel is a very high ranking
individual in American military. So why
would he participate in this operation?
That's very strange. Um, and even though
he was injured, seriously wounded
according to Trump, he still managed to
hike up a 7,000 ft mountain ridge line
and hide in a crib in the Zag mountains
for 48 hours despite his wounds. Also,
we don't know who he is.
He He's never been identified. He was
never interviewed by the press, which is
unusual because once because if you
rescue the man, you make him into a
national TV star, right? So, there are a
lot of issues with this story. All
right. So, um, Emmer, could you do me a
favor and just read the summary?
>> Okay.
So, to sum up, anti-aircraft equipment
that supposedly didn't exist shot down
an F-15 and apparently an A-10 Warthog.
The same day, a seriously wounded man
climbed a 1 uh 2.1 km uh kilome
mountain. The US seized an airfield 200
miles inside a country it's at war with
next to one of its most strategic
nuclear sites and deployed hundreds of
troops all apparently unimpeded. Lost
two planes to sand and destroyed their
own helicopters. Videos show heavy
clashes, missiles raining down, but not
a single person got even wounded. And
the man at the center of it all, nobody
knows who he is. Completely anonymous.
zero pictures, but Trump says he is safe
and sound and so is the rescued Aton
Warthog pilot who also remains
anonymous. Okay, so again, this story
makes absolutely no sense. Um, you we
don't understand why they had to build
an airport. We don't understand how
these planes got destroyed. And the fact
that there are no casualties absolutely
makes no sense whatsoever. Okay, so
maybe something else is going on and
people online are speculating that this
was actually a failed ground invasion
and the mission was to sneak into Iran's
nuclear power plant located in the area
and steal Iran's uh enriched uranium
which it would need to build a nuclear
weapon. Okay? And by doing that you deny
the Iranians capacity to build a nuclear
weapon and you can declare a victory.
Okay? All right. So, what's the evidence
for this? Well, on March 7th, 2020 uh
2026, so um at the beginning of this
war, a journalist named Barack David uh
Barack Ravid wrote an article in Axios
uh which is a Washingtonbased uh media
outlet saying that the US is considering
spending special sending special forces
to seize Iran's nuclear stock power.
Okay. Now, Ver Rabbit is is famous in in
Washington DC because he's very close
with the Israelis. He himself is
Israeli. So, he's able to get a lot of
information from the government. Okay.
So, from March 7th onward, there was
news reporting that the Americans would
insert special forces to steal the
uranium. No one took this seriously
because it's so stupid. Are you
seriously going to send in like a
hundred guys into the middle of Iran
and like hope they can sneak into a
military base and steal that uranium and
then run away? THAT'S JUST NO
ONE WOULD do that. Okay, so everyone's
like, "This is just this is just a scar.
This is just disinformation." Okay, no
one took it seriously. I didn't take
this seriously at all. But then
4 days ago, sorry not 4 days, a week
ago, the Washington Post
leaks a Pentagon plan to do exactly
that. And it's a very detailed plan that
involves hundreds or thousands of
troops. Okay. And the idea is to build a
leting strip near the power plant in
order to land forces, in order to land
um equipment.
So, this is a very detailed plan. The
problem, so when this first came out,
again, I didn't take it seriously
because this is so Are you
seriously going to build an airport by
yourself in the middle of Iran and hope
the Iranians don't notice
and you're going to land a thousand
troops in the middle of mountains where
they're going to rain missiles on you?
It makes no sense what whatsoever. Okay.
But unfortunately,
if you just look at what happened this
weekend, this is the plan they used
where they sent 155 aircraft to try to
create a landing strip. They sent in
special forces. It was exact exactly the
plan that Washington Post reported on.
Okay. But then the question is, wait a
minute here. This is a top secret
military plan. How did the Washington
Post get this? Well, the answer is
because we assume that some generals
gave it to them. All right. Peter Hex,
the secretary of war for Donald Trump,
fired
the top generals for
the military.
And we don't know why.
There was never a reason given, but we
can suspect what happened was this.
Donald Trump asked the generals to come
up with a plan to steal the uranium. And
the generals are like, "Let's just humor
him. Okay, let's come up with this
stupid insane plan that there's no way
this guy would agree to." And then we'll
forget about it. They present to Donald
Trump and Donald Trump's like, "THIS IS
A BRILLIANT PLAN. THIS IS A GREAT MOVIE.
LET'S DO THIS, GUYS." THE GENERALS are
like, "Oh my god, he is insane.
Oh my god, we are so screwed, man. And
they refuse to carry it out. So Peter XF
is like, well then you're fired. Okay.
And then Peter XF orders the new
generals to execute this plan.
So again, we don't know what happened.
We will never know what happened, but
the evidence suggests that this this
might have been a failed ground
invasion. Another piece of evidence to
suggest that this was a fail gun
invasion with the intention of stealing
the uranium is that the Iranians were
able to recover ID
from
dur in the crime side. Okay. And it
turns out that this woman happens to
specialize in nuclear technology, an
engineer. Why would you need an engineer
who specializ in nuclear technology to
rescue a pilot?
Right. That's kind of strange.
And the Americans have done stupid
things like this before. Okay. So, in
1980,
in 1980,
um the Americans implemented something
called Operation Eagle Claw. And the
idea was that
at this time the Iranians had taken
hostages, American hostages in Tran, the
American embassy. Okay. So Jimmy Carter
the president authorized a rescue
operation. So but Iran was too big. So
what they did was the American military
set up a foreign operating base in the
desert halfway between uh Persian Gulf
and Tran. When they landed in their base
there there was a sandstorm and a lot of
their planes malfunction and they
recognize that oh my god it's really
hard to go through such an operation in
Iran. So we should just go home. Okay.
So that was 1980 when Americans were
were pretty sane.
Unfortunately, Americans are no longer
sane. Okay. This is June 3rd when the
Americans swept into Venezuela and
kidnapped their president Maduro, thus
ending the conflict between Venezuela
and America. This is great TV. The plan
worked out perfectly. It showed that
Delforce was invincible. And
unfortunately, Donald Trump believes
this, okay? He believes that we did this
in Venezuela, we can do this in Iran.
And this explains how and why Donald
Trump would agree to such an insane plan
as to try to build an American military
base in the middle of your enemy. Okay.
So the main message here is that whoever
is leaving America whether it's Donald
Trump or other people for whatever
reason they believe that optics is all
that matters. Okay they think that
reality is a movie a Hollywood movie is
if they can script it properly then the
movie will turn out to be a wonderful
wonderful thing. Okay, this is a war
about optics rather than strategy
and unfortunately this is just how
America's going to fight the war from
now on. Okay, so let's just discuss what
you need to win a war. If you are
fighting a war, what are three things
you need to look at? Okay, and there are
three things and that's it. First thing
you want to look at is economics.
Okay, economics.
Second thing you want to look at
is organization.
The third thing you want to look at
is logistics.
All right. So, what what what do I mean
by this? Well, the first thing is
resource management.
In other words, you're trying to win a
war as cheaply and as quickly as
possible.
Okay? Unfortunately, right now, the
Americans are not fighting a war of
economics. If you're spending $300
million in military equipment in order
to rescue a pilot, you're not going to
win this war. Okay? So, econ economics
is really m is really important. Second
is idea of organization which is the
implementation of strategy.
Right? So you have a strategy and then
you
implement it. And here what's really
important is the simpler the strategy
the easier easier it is to implement.
Okay? You want the strategy to be very
simple because you have to organize it
implement it. So if you are trying to
build an air base in the middle of Iran
so you can extract extract uranium from
Iranians that's not a good organization.
Okay, this thing is going to blow up in
your face. The third issue is logistics
which is just supply. Okay, supply.
Making sure that your forces have the
necessary equipment, the resources in
order to fight the war effectively. And
right now the Americans are not
concerned with any of these issue. E
economics, organization and logistics.
But these are the three major
issues that you need to figure out if
you want to win a war. Okay?
And unfortunately, right now, the
Americans are too much focused on optics
and narrative.
So that's why I think the Americans will
ultimately lose this war because the
Iranians are actually fighting a real
war where they're trying to win the war
as cheaply as possible with where
they're implementing a very simple
strategy that allows for proper
organization and they and they are
trying to um maintain logistics. Okay,
the Americans are just trying to
uh win the war
in the most Hollywood fashion as
possible and this is going to lead to
disaster both in the short term and the
long term. So the question then is why
Americans like this and unfortunately
the answer is because there's too much
cooperation between Hollywood and the
Pentagon. All right. So this is a movie
saving part saving part right in the and
this was made in the year 1998. Okay.
And this is one of the um highest
growing the highest grossing films in
Hollywood history where a private uh
named Ryan of course
he is lost behind enemy lines in the
Europe and his brothers all killed. So
his mother writes a very angry letter to
General Marshall and says, "All my sons
are dead except for one and he's
missing." And so General Marshall is
like, "We can't have this, okay? This is
this makes us look bad. We have to win
the home front." Okay, Europe, this
warfront, it's secondary to the home
front. We need to make sure that the
American people are fully behind this
war. So he sends a team led by uh this
man played by Tom Hanks to go and save
Private Ryan. And they do, but at the
cost of his life. Okay. And this movie
is based on a letter that Abraham
Lincoln wrote to a mother in the
American Civil War. Okay. 1864. And this
considered one Abraham Lincoln's most um
brilliant
pieces of writing. Okay. So um Amber,
could you help me read this, please?
Dear madam, I have been shown in the
files of the war department a statement
of the
adjunant general of Massachusetts that
you are the mother of five sons who have
died gloriously on the field of battle.
I feel how weak and fruitless must be
any words of mine which should attempt
to beguile you from the grief of a loss
so overwhelming. But I cannot refrain
from tendering to you the consolation
that may be found in the thanks of the
republic they died to save. I pray that
our heavenly father may as sewage the
anguish of your bare
>> bereiement
>> bereiement and leave you only the
cherished memory of the loved and lost
and the solemn pride that must be yours
to have laid so costly a sacrifice upon
the altar of freedom. Yours very
sincerely and respectfully. A Lincoln.
>> Great. Great. Okay. Um, the sacrifice
upon the altar of freedom. Okay. So, our
democracy, our republic is our God and
our sacrifice is worth it as long as we
can maintain
our freedom and our liberty. Okay? And
this is the defining
theology of the American military.
All right. Um, this has led to
the military becoming more of a
propaganda machine. Okay, so this is the
movie Blackhawk Down. If you saw the
movie, then it's about these special
forces, Delta Force that go in and save
a pilot
uh when they are when his helicopter was
brought down in uh Somalia. Okay. Okay.
And this was a b based on a book by Mark
Balden
writing about the incident which
happened in the late '9s. Okay. All
right. The problem is that this movie is
complete BS. In the book, what happened
was that the helicopter was brought down
and the pilot was taken hostage by the
Somali. But he was treated very well and
eventually he was allowed to go home
after the government paid a ransom.
Okay, that's what happened in real life.
But in the movie, what happened was that
Delta Force went in and saved the pilot
from those trying to kidnap him. And
this goes back to the to the mythology
of No Men Left Behind. Now, there's a
very important scene in Black Hawkdown
where a general confronts Delta Force
and Delta Force was created for
operations like this. And what and what
the general says to Delta Force is you
guys are a bunch of cowboys. And what
he's saying is that you guys, you double
force, you special forces, you guys
never you guys think you're superior to
everyone. You think that we all revolve
around you. You think that we we should
all serve you. You guys are ego-driven.
All you care about is glory for
yourself. And eventually your ego, your
arrogance are going to be are going to
be your downfall as well as the downfall
of the American military. Okay.
Um this is a movie. This is Jessica
Lynch.
And in 2003, she was serving in the war
in Iran, Iraq. actually Iraq, sorry. And
her co her um her team got lost and they
were ambushed by the Iraqis and then she
was um kidnapped. But then because she
was injured, the military, the Iraqi
military sent her to a hospital, a civil
hospital. And the people in the hospital
treated her very very well and they
actually tried to send her home in an
ambulance. But when the ambulance tried
to reach the Americans, Americans bombed
the ambulance. So the ambulance had to
turn back and but but the Iraqis
informed the Americans where she was and
told the Iraqis, you and so told the
Americans, you you can come and pick her
up anytime, okay? She's she's safe.
We're taking care of her, but if you
want but if you want to take her home,
it's okay. The Americans response
organized special forces to go and
rescue her even though she was not in
danger. and the media report that she
was raped, she was beaten, and she was
held hostage. Okay, so that's what the
Pentagon does. The Pentagon is a
propaganda machine. It doesn't care
about the truth. It just cares about
trying to create a Hollywood movie out
of a movie. Okay? So, Pentagon is
concerned first and foremost about
creating a Hollywood movie out of a war.
That's its own that that's its
mentality. Um, we know this because
Jessica Lynch after she was set free
went on TV and said that the military is
lying about the incident. I was never
beaten. I was never in danger. The
people in the hospital treat me very
nice. In fact, the nurses sang me to
sleep because they were so concerned
about my welfare. All right. All right.
So, this is a huge problem for the
American military, for the Pentagon as
they fight this war. You can pull this
crap when you're fighting Somalis and
Iraqis, but against the Iranians, you
need total war. You need to focus on
economics, organization, and logistics.
Stop doing this crap of optics, okay,
and narrative. Unfortunately, it's it it
has it is now the very mentality of the
Pentagon to turn war into a Hollywood
movie. All right. So this is a paper
written by Kennor Merles at Brown
University and what this author talks
about is how the Pentagon and Hollywood
are aligned together. All right. So so
so can you read the three major take
takeaways? Um um Amber
>> in exchange for the use of military
equipment and personnel movies and TV
program producers must comply with
Pantukon entertainment policy including
script changes to align with military
goals including recruitment and public
relations.
Since the inception of the Hollywood
entertainment industry more than a
century ago, over 2,500 war themed
movies and TV programs have been made
with Pentagon assistance. Pentagon
assisted movies uh movies and TV shows
frame US wars as necessary and glorious,
downplaying the ignoring uh downplaying
or ignoring the human, social, and
environmental devastation war causes,
particularly for civilians. US soldiers
are typically cast as noble protagonists
while those non US people's people's
deemed enemies of America are constantly
stereotyped.
>> Okay. So what this paper is saying is
that the Pentagon uses Hollywood in
order to indoctrinate and brainwash
American people to believe that war is
good. Okay. So that's true. But what's
also true is that by working with
Hollywood,
it brainwashes the Pentagon to believe
that war can be like Hollywood. It can
be perfected. As long as you create a
good script, it will work out in the
end. Okay? And this will lead to
disaster in Iran. So think about again
Donald Trump where it's a failed ground
invasion.
And so if it's a failed innovation, what
you do is you go back, you sit down with
Pentagon planners and you figure out
what went wrong and how to never make
the mistake again. But Donald Trump does
not want to admit it was a failed ground
invasion. So they made up a stupid
Hollywood movie, a stupid Hollywood
script that this was a rescue of a
American pilot that it will turn into a
Hollywood movie at some point. And so
from their perspective, this is a huge
success. Okay. And this is going to lead
to problems because if it's a huge
success, then do it again,
right? And if people think it's failure,
prove that they're wrong by having
successful ground invasion. All right?
So unfortunately, the fact of the matter
is that America right now, the American
military, it's too dominated by special
forces, by Delta Force, by Navy Seals
who are interested only in their own
personal glory. Okay? Okay, I'm not
saying I'm not saying all of them, but
I'm saying there's quite a lot of them
who understand that after this war is
over, they can make they can sign a book
deal. They can write a book, make
millions of dollars, which will be
turned into a movie, and they'll and
then they'll be a superstar. Okay, so
that's what that's how they think and
what they should be thinking about are
organization, logistics, and e economics
because these are the three things that
win wars. All right. Okay. Any
questions, guys?
I personally also think that America is
likely to um make a movie about saving
the pirates in Iran. But I think it will
be similar as uh saving pirate Ryan. But
could you please tell me whether the
plot of saving uh private Ryan is true
or it's just made made it up?
>> Yeah, it it's it's just a madeup movie.
>> Yeah. Most of these things are are made
up, okay? They don't really turn out the
way that that they they do. But like the
problem with Hollywood is that it's so
seductive. It's so attractive that
people think they're true. Okay? People
think that the movie is more true than
real life. And that's how not only the
Pentagon works, but also like all of
American society works now. Americans
live in their own fantasy world created
by Hollywood. And the realities of war
are too far away from for them to care
about. Okay? I mean, Americans think
that, oh, at worst case scenario, my my
the food prices will go up. And you
can't really imagine how this war will
ever forever change the world as well as
America. Okay. Um, yeah.
>> How many more of these spectacles do you
think America can afford recreating? or
let's say how many more times would
America like learn to understand that
this this like
like optical
Hollywood act will not no longer work
for their plan. Will they ever will they
ever work?
>> Okay, that's a great um question to
answer is they will never ever learn.
Okay, because they live in a different
reality. Like Donald Trump surrounds
himself with people who just tell him
what he wants to hear. And the reason
why he's able to go in front of the
press and say what a great success
in that that we had in saving a pilot.
Okay. The reason why the reason why he's
able to do that is because he himself
believes this. Okay. He lives in
alternate reality, a fantasy land. And
that's why he's able to to so
convincingly
tell the press and the American people
that this was a great success. Even
though if you look at the evidence, this
was a tremendous failure. And
unfortunately, this will not change. As
this war continues, you have more
incidents like this. We just say it it's
a failure that the American military and
and Donald Trump um spin as a tremendous
success. And so the American people will
continue to believe that this war is
going well. Okay? And and we know this
because this is exactly what happened in
Ukraine. For the past few years, Russia
has been dominating the battlefield and
has been um killing many, many
Ukrainians. It's been a disaster for
Ukraine. But you don't know this if
you're American, if you're an average
American because the news tell you that
this war is going great. One more day,
guys, and Putin will fall. One more day
the Russian economy will collapse. The
Russian people will revolt and Putin
will be out of office. One more day and
the and Ukraine Ukrainians will reach
Moscow. Okay. Same situation here where
one more day and Iran will surrender.
One more day the Iranian economy will
collapse. The people will revolt and
then we'll have peace in the Middle
East. Okay. So unfortunately
this is modern war where it's really
about optics. But again you want to win
this war don't focus on optics because
ultimately you're the one focusing
yourself. Okay. Yeah.
But despite that America is strong in
this kind of Hollywood and war scene but
I think they still holds dominant
position and still holds the strongest
uh military weapon in the world. and
they still have, you know, the
sovereignty to state and control many of
those countries. How can you explain
that?
>> Okay, you're actually right in that
America is still the empire and America
will not fall because of this war. Worst
case scenario, they lose, they they go
home. Okay, so one thing that I I I want
us to think about is that the strategic
objectives of the Americans and the
Iranians are not actually in conflict
with each other. Okay. So if you look at
the Iranians,
they want to um get America out of
Middle East. All right?
They want to destroy the global economy
and they want to deter Israel. Okay?
Does that make sense? These are the
three strategic objectives of Iran. to
remove America out of the Middle East
forever to deter Israel. You can't
destroy Israel because Israel has
nuclear weapon, but you show Israel
you're strong and you you can hurt them
if you if Israel goes too far and you
want to destroy the global economy
because you want to reset the global
economy in a way that benefits you.
Okay, so these are three strategic
objectives of Iran in this war. Let's
look at America. America is okay. Uh
destroy
Iran
as a nation state.
Okay. Which basically means you destroy
the desalination plants, the power
plants, the universities, the reservoirs
and you try to create ethnic conflict.
Okay. Uh buffanize
uh Iran. Okay. So you basically
encourage ethnic uprisings throughout
the uh country. Okay. Now the last thing
you want to do is isolate Iran.
So you want to destroy Iran's capacity
to trade with Russia and China. Okay. So
if you look at what's happening, one
really strange thing about this war is
that these strategic objectives are not
in conflict with each other. Even if
Iran is able to achieve its strategic
objectives, it doesn't prevent America
from achieving its strategic object
objectives. So in other words, at the
end of this war, what what we can expect
is both countries achieve their
strategic objectives. Okay, which is to
say that America is now out of the
Middle East. Um Israel is humbled and
the global economy is destroyed. But at
the same time, Iran is destroyed as a
nation state. It's balconized. Uh, it's
basically born back to the stone age.
All right.
All right. Does that make sense? Okay.
So, and unfortunately, because the
shooting objectives are different, both
nations think they'll win the war. All
right. Maybe objectively we think that
America is losing the war. But from
American perspective, the way that they
frame their strategic objectives means
that from their perspective they are
winning the war and that's why they and
that's why they think that any day now
Iran will surrender. But from the
Iranian perspective, they think they're
winning the war and they think that any
day now America will surrender. That's
why it's impossible to get the two to
negotiate a peace settlement. Okay? Does
that make sense?
Okay. All right. Okay. All right. So, on
Thursday, we're do something really
interesting. Okay. We are having a
midterm examination,
but rather than me test you, you're
going to test me.
Okay? So, what I want you to do is think
about what we've learned this semester
and try to figure out where I could be
wrong or where the problems, my logic
are. I want you to test me. Okay? And
this is also true for YouTube where um
if you think that there's something
wrong with my logic, if you dispute what
I say, then uh raise a question and then
my wife will read the YouTube comments
and then pick out questions for me to
answer on Thursday. Okay? So on Thursday
will be a midterm examination, but
rather than me test you, you will test
me. Okay? and be as hard and as harsh
and as difficult as you want to be. I
enjoy being questioned and examined.
Okay, so Thursday will be a lot of fun.
I'll see you guys then.
>> Yeah.